I think if I'm writing something that  feels truthful  um and sort of electric and a bit  dangerous because it feels truthful  um then I just my hope is that it will  land in the same way with other people  as well so that's it I mean and it's  it's so it's hope has so much to do with  writing like when you're writing you  were just hoping that it reaches people  you're hoping that you're not alone and  thinking this this is funny or that this  is moving and so I think you go in with  all the Hope in the world that it will  that it will resonate in this way and  when it does it's just such a huge  relief um from a creative professional  point of view but also just from a human  point of view that you're not completely  on your own on this island going like  that's funny right guys